we've got twenty nine point nine six is
being divided by 0.7 so hopefully you've
already learned how to do long division
and now all we're doing is we're adding
this component of adding the decimal in
there so what you want is you want this
number here that's going into twenty
nine point nine six to be a whole number
right so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna move the decimal point enough
places to the right so that it becomes a
whole number however many places we move
this to the right we want to do the same
thing with the number underneath the
division bar okay so I move this one one
to the right I want to move this one to
one to the right so let me just rewrite
this now we have seven is going into two
hundred and ninety nine point six okay
so a little bit easier now so now we
just go ahead and proceed like normal we
just do our division seven goes into two
no seven goes into twenty nine yes how
many times four so I put the four right
above the twenty-nine above the nine 4
times 7 is 28
okay subtract that's gonna be one nine
six by the way this decimal point you
just want to bring straight up and put
it on the division bar so I just brought
it straight up you know 7 goes into 19
how many times two times notice how I'm
keeping these lined up so that's 14
seven times 2 is 40 am subtracting
that's 56 and seven goes into 56 eight
times and again notice how everything's
lined up that's 56 zero remainder so
forty two point eight is our final
answer let's look at another example
here we have 40 is divided by two point
five okay so let's set it up we've got
40 is divided by two point five okay
could you see this number on the outside
we want this just to be a whole number
so we're gonna make it a whole number by
moving the decimal point one place to
the right okay and if we do that to this
number we also want to do the same thing
to the number underneath the division
bar right now the decimal point is here
at the right of the number we're gonna
move it one place and so we have to put
a placeholder there that's we put a zero
for a placeholder so now the decimals
right there so let's rewrite it we have
25 is going into 400 and there's our
decimal point let's just bring it right
up there on the division bar okay so
you're with me so far
so now does 25 go into four no does 25
go into 40
yes how many times one time so 1 times
25 is 25 we subtract how many times does
25 going to 150 now just a hint when
you're working with 25 you can think of
quarters like 25 cents so how many times
how many quarters go into a dollar 50
well that's a six quarters right four
quarters in a dollar plus two more for
the fifty cents that's six quarters so
six times 25 is a dollar 50 we subtract
zero remaining so our final answer is
just going to be 16 so I hope this helps
you to understand how to work with
dividing decimals better in this video I
have another video I talked about
multiplying decimals if you want to or
need to check that out and subscribe to
the channel check out some more videos
on my channel Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and I look forward to
seeing the future videos I'll talk to
you soon